e
[Musique]
oh
à
il est 7h15 ce sont les laudes le
premier temps de prière de la journée
les profanes pourrait croire qu'il n'ya
qu'une sorte de liturgie mais en fait
chaque communauté de religieuses peut
apporter des nuances des rythmes
différents
[Musique]
les soeurs de ronchamp recherche la
sobriété et la simplicité
depuis leur implantation il y a dix ans
sur la colline de ronchamp les clarisses
venue de besançon ont accueilli quatre
soeurs elles sont arrivées avec leur
formation et leurs habitudes j'ai pas
réalisé au départ que pour décréter
soeur qui arrivait d'ailleurs il fallait
beaucoup plus de temps d'inculturation
que de l'imaginer je pensais qu'en deux
trois ans cet effet et c'est pas vrai il
faut vraiment pas loin de 8 à 10 ans une
soeur se sentent vraiment appartenir à
une nouvelle communauté comment vous
expliquez cela
parce que son dessert qui ont été si je
puis dire formé ailleurs dans un autre
style dans une autre forme de pensée
peut être dans une forme ou une autre
forme d'expression donc quelque part
même si elles ont choisi de venir ici
balayer d'un revers de main tout ce qui
vous a modelé pendant des années ça se
fait pas en 24 heures ça se fait pas en
un an ça se fait pas en 5 ans c'est par
ici il y à bien un lieu où les
différences culturelles s'exprime c'est
la cuisine les soeurs prépare à tour de
rôle les repas les vendredi et samedi
c'est sur marie thérèse j'ai vécu tant
bocaux de payer et j'aime beaucoup
d'aidé
ray pas très épicé des indiens chinoise
ces choses comme ça et c'est pas du goût
de
peut-être les français qui aiment
beaucoup de sources avec le crès
1000v qu'elle a appris les premiers
arrivés d'afghans en france elle est
allée à périr des familles à colmar
saumon
la nique communautaire ça c'est toujours
quelque part des cas pas parce que voilà
on est on ne peut pas avoir de masques
sur le long terme quoi donc ça ça ça
oblige ça stimule plutôt parce que c'est
aussi une chance de voilà de de faire un
travail sur soi pour voir vraiment
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui me tient ici
qu'est ce qui est important pour moi
pour que ben j'arrive à dépasser les les
petites chicaneries des femmes ensemble
c'est pas facile car il ya toujours des
rivalités un petit peu sournoise et
toujours on est peut-être que l'art y
est on est on est plein de fois on est
plein d'amour et pleine de compassion à
peine de charité mais quelque part la
nature humaine féminine
ça s'accroche à tout petit peu donc une
fois qu'on en prend conscience on
s'adapte
les hommes les autres avec joie tout en
se disant bien qu'il n'est plus question
de des soeurs de besançon des soeurs de
sion des soeurs de norvège des soeurs
des sortes de belgique seuls les chefs
de ronchamp
et c'est par des petits riens que les
liens se tissent ici le lave vaisselle
et très rarement utilisée
on s'en sert que quand tu as énormément
non et parce que mon honneur soit
que la vaisselle et italiens ambiguïté
et de communion de fraternité donc c'est
aussi ce notre lieu de récréation les
clarisses veulent bâtir leur avenir sur
quatre piliers les rencontres
interreligieuses la liturgie l'écologie
et l'interculturalité
l'histoire de l'interculturalité
l'histoire d'être sur un lieu de passage
ça nous ouvre et dès qu'on est ouvert
c'est la vie qui rentre dès qu'on se
ferme si la mort est celui qui nous qui
nous tient ensemble c c'est jésus-christ
et chacune dans sa relation personnelle
à jésus et c'est pour lui qu'on est là
et là au moins c'est la base où on est
tous d'accord
moi je me contente qu'on soit diverses
quoi parce que c'est peut-être parfois
rude mais c'est une richesse quoi c'est
une richesse et c'est ce qui nous permet
de pouvoir avoir cette ouverture
à l'international à l'universel par
rapport aux gens qui aiment fréquents
ces hommes ou femmes qui viennent de
loin ou de tout à côté pour passer une
ou plusieurs nuits dont l'une des
chambres du monastère nous les
rencontrerons demain